やあ、みんな！はじめしゃちょーだよ
動画の一番最初のコメントを当てようとするゲームをやったんだけど
あのーマジ無理。
全然当たんねぇーし
動画、実はこれね一時間以上取ってたんですげぇ長くなったし編集もめんどくさかったんで後半になっちゃったよ！
前編まだ見てない人は前編から見るんだよ！
では後半どうぞ
ﾋﾟｺﾝﾋﾟｺﾝ
「演技表現の大切さがとてもわかる動画」
はい
ング...フッフゥフ
すげぇグッドの数だねぇ
「このBGMを使えばどんな動画でも面白くなる説」
この曲最強
あーなるほどね、神曲
いくよ！
次！
「はじめしゃちょーと赤ちゃん」
俺もそう願いたい。
あははは
なんかこう癖のある動画ならいけそうな気がするんだよね
｢人の乳首を吸うことができるサイコロ｣
｢スライムで風呂作ってみた｣
たしかにこれはね
なんだろうな、、どっちだろうな、、
これはまじで
いきますよ
｢iPhoneを天ぷらにされたらどう反応するのか？｣
そらちぃの反応面白い系もあると思うし
このネタの発想自体面白い
どっちに転ぶかだねぇ
おれもキレますわ
｢ありえない高額な駐車料金が請求されるドッキリ｣
これでもね大変だったんですよ、企画が
これは東海オンエアコメントしてそうだな
東海オンエアがコメントするとしたら
『謎のアカウント｢コッシー」の正体を暴く』
これtwitterでコッシーのアカウントが、怪しいのがあって
それの正体を暴くって動画なんですけど
それはあるよ！
高評価１６万高評価だよ！
どういうこと名前ミスったってどういうこと？
コッシーって名前だったんじゃない？この人
っとなるとこれもいけるんじゃないかな
『怪しすぎるアカウント｢謎の犬｣の正体を暴きます』
読めないぞ、これほんとに
『【斉藤さん】はじめしゃちょー本人だとバレるのか？』
いよいよやばいよこれ
「サイレントはじめの部屋」
まったくしゃべらない動画なんですけれども
なるほどね、特定の人物を、、、
ｵｵｵｵｲ!お前ら！！！
「寝てる人を起こさずに電球でテニス」
「【最強】３０mのバネが飛び出るポテチの筒を作ってみた」
「オレの家の階段を滝にしてみた」
最初に君の名は。の話してたんですよね
猫のマークでしたね
「兄弟で語る、はじめしゃちょーの黒歴史。」
めっちゃ兄弟仲いいね
おもしろww
なんかスイカのTシャツ着てたね
「コンビニアメリカンドッグ日本１決定戦」
セブンのが一番好き
結局セブンが最強みたいな
「コンビニのたまごサンドNo.1を決めましょう」
ツナサンドの方が好き
結局セブンイレブンが最強
おもしろい
すばらしい、、これは、、
「すき屋全メニュー食ってみた」
これは東海オンエアとかいろんなメンツでやったんですけど
最強のメンバー
ﾌﾋｯﾋｯﾋｯﾋww
「ブタメン１００個食ってみた　前編」
はじめ食わなすぎｗｗみたいな
ブタメンって食べたことない
さあ、果たして
え、五年前、、？
そんなにやってたかYouTube
『[戦慄]激辛ぺヤングにデスソースをかけるドッキリ』
二人とも若いみたいな
まさき強くねみたいな
なるほどね～
さあ、こい！
「【閲覧注意】乗り物酔いしないオレがイスで超回転した結果...」
汚いってコメント
くだらない
ﾌﾍﾍﾍ
やばいねこれ
ｳﾋｬﾋｬﾋｬﾋｬﾋｬ
かっこいいんじゃないですか～？
「水を何リットル飲めば尿意がくるのか」
音がえぐ～
これは汚い、間違いない
これは汚いでしかないでしょ
じゃあ汚いにしといて
かっこいい
所沢との出会いですね
「思ったより巨大なクマが家にやってきた」
ｸﾊﾊﾊﾊ
俺どうしようもねーな
「毒々しい紫色の巨大なクマがやってきた」
ちょっと～
「帰ってきたらベイマックスがいるドッキリ」
なんか、黒髪珍しいねみたいな
あんまり黒髪してないから
どっちか当たってくれ、、、！頼む！
みんな！黒髪でいることにするよ！
あぶね～、一歩間違えてたらおわってたよこれ